الينا الان من عمان فايز الدويري
المحلل العسكري والخبير العسكري معنا
سياده اللواء
بطبيعه الحال هناك كما تقول روسيا احباط
لمحاوله اوكرانيه
بمضرب
مواقع داخل موسكوبي مسيرات وهو ما نجحت
فيه سابقا اوكرانيا
انت كان لك حديث سابق بانه من الصعب
الاسقاط الطائرات المسيره باستخدام انظمه
دفاعيه كيف تعلق على الروايه الروسيه التي
تقول بانهم اسقطوها
يعني انا قلت ان الامن المطلق غير موجود
ولابد من حدوث اختراقات وقد تسقط
نسبه كبيره جدا من الطائرات وقد تسقط نسبه
مئه بالمئه في بعض الحالات لكن تستطيع بعض
الطائرات ان تخترق وتصل الى اهداف الان
هذا الخبر لا يزال ضمن فتره قصيره جدا
المعلومات غير كامله المحلل عليه ان يذهب
الى البعد التحليلي بعيدا عن ايه موثوقيه
انما يسكر قدراته وخبرته الان الحديث عن
مصنع العاب ناريه
الان ما هي الاحتمالات
قد سنبقي احتمال وصول طائره مسيره الى هذا
المصنع
سنذهب الى الاحتمالات الاخرى عندما نتحدث
عن مصنع العاب ناريه نتحدث عن شغلات او
وسائط اشعال
معظمها تتكون من المتفجرات الواطيه لكن
جميعها لديها وسيله اشعال وعذرا للحديث
الفني لديها وسيله اشعال من المتفجرات
العاليه ذات الحساسيه العاليه جدا لانه
كلما زاد درجه حساسيه متفجرات انخفضت
قوتها فنستخدم وانا ضابط هندسه سنستخدم
وسائط اشعال بسيطه جدا من حيث الحجم حساسه
جدا من اجل احداث الشعله الاولى والاسبارك
لتنطلق الالعاب الناريه هذه العمليه
تكون اذا كانت عمليات الخزن غير دقيقه اذا
جرت عمليات
متماس كهربائي اذا حدث عمليات تلحيم
مواسير اي خطا قد يفضي الى حدوث هذه
الكارثه ويسبب الشععل الاولى او السبارك
التي ستظلي اذا دعني الاحتمال فقط نعم حتى
الان التصريحات الرسميه تصب في موضوع انه
لم يتم الاستهداف وانما حدث هو حادث عرضي
اصاب المصنع لكن كان سؤالي لك عن ما تقوله
الان روسيا بانها بالامس اسقطت طائرتين لم
تصب احد باذى هذا هو سؤالي بالنظر الى ان
المسيرات هي المستخدمه في العمق الروسي
ونجحت اوكرانيا في ذلك اكثر من مره
سيدي
نجحت بما هو اصعب من هذا الحدث هذا الحدث
اذا كان مصنع العاب ناريه لن يكون محصلا
لن يكون محمي سيد فايز لا يتحدث اسمح لي
فقط لا لا نتحدث عن المصنع لا لانه
المعلومات الوارده حتى الان من الجانب
الروسي وهي التي نلتزم بنقلها بانه حدث
عرضي لا نريد ان ندخل في تفاصيل ما الذي
حدث في المصنع لا هناك حادثه بالامس اسقاط
طائرتين مسيرتين كانت تريد ان تستهدف موقع
داخل موسكو وتم استهدافها من قبل الدفاع
الروسيه واسقطتها
امكانيه اسقاط الطائرات المسيره كان صعبا
كما ذكرت اكثر من مره فهل تعتقد بان هذه
الروايه الروسيه صحيحه بانه بالفعل تم
اسقاط طائرات مسيره هل هذا ممكن
يا سيدي اسقاطها وارد جدا ويمكن ان تسقط
ما يرقى الى 90% كلا الجانبين اذا عدنا
الى مقاربه احصائيه لاعداد الهجمات ومن
سواء مسيرات خاصه شاهد في الجانب
الاوكراني او مسيارات اوكرانيه في بعض
التصاريح التصريحات كانت نسبه ابطال
الفاعليه سواء بالتدمير او بالبعد
الالكتروني ترقى الى مئه بالمئه ثلاث
طائرات من ثلاث طائرات لكن السؤال الاخر
كيف تستطيع بعض الطائرات الوصول الى
المناطق
الحساسه جدا عدم تصل الى قبه الكرملين الم
تصل الى ابراج موسكو الم تصل الى بعض
الاماكن قرب جسر كرش اذا لهذا السبب اقول
لك يعني كما قيل قديما وعذرا في العباره
كلمه مستحيل في قاموس الحمقى وبالتالي عدد
اسقاط كافه الطائرات قد يحدث مره قد يحدث
مرتين لكن سيتم نجاح بعض الطائرات في
الوصول الى اهدافها لانه هناك عمليه سباق
تقني من كلا الجانبين الجانب الذي يوظف
الطائرات والجانب الذي يتصدى للطائرات
وكلما تم اكتشاف ثغره في احد الطائرات
ومعالجتها يتم تطوير القدرات لها اذا نحن
امام عمليه ارتقاء نوعي سواء في نوعيه
الطائرات وكفاءتها او في القدره على
مواجهتها شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه الاضاحات
فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
اللواء فايز الدويري شكرا جزيلا